you are a giant female anaconda in
Venezuela you're 13 feet long and you
are hungry no make that you are starving
and you've got your little asides on the
largest rodents on the planet
capybaras adults can grow more than four
feet long and can top 100 pounds you be
anaconda can't really see your prey all
that well but your tongue pulls in scent
molecules that tell you this is the
massive meal you want to swallow in one
prolonged gulp both you and the cat
laverra's spend most of your time in the
water and one unfortunate capybara will
have nowhere to hide when you hunt it at
high speed you slither under water
popping your head out to make sure your
aim is true the big reason you're so
focused on a satisfying meal is that
you're about to mate and only well-fed
snakes breathe successfully once you get
pregnant you won't eat again until your
babies are born 7 months later so you'd
better stuff yourself - the scales
now
these birds can save themselves but the
capybara it's a goner anacondas don't
poison their prey they ambush them they
bite then coil around and crush the
surprised creature to death
your death grip is so fierce the victim
not only can't breathe its blood can't
circulate you've suffered for this meal
the capybara took a bite out of you but
you get the last laugh when your elastic
jaws begin swallowing your enormous
victim head first your last meal before
mating has taken six hours to ingest not
digest just get it into your gut
the digestion takes several days after
that you'll be fit and full ready for
that successful breeding